[Music]
our beaches have always been popular for
fishing and white baiting and it makes
life easier if you can drive your
equipment out to your favorite spot
under the northern Pegasus Bay by law
that's still fine but there are some
rules around vehicles you need to be
aware of you can only drive on the beach
for approved purposes this includes
launching a boat or transporting
equipment for fishing white baiting or
making a chi here at kuraki if you hold
a mobility parking permit you can also
bring your car onto the beach but
recreational driving and driving just
for pleasure is not allowed and neither
a two-wheeled motor bikes you also need
to stick to the designated areas which
are from the Waimakariri River mouth to
the red post located 2.5 kilometres
north of the pines beach and from the
north of the ashley rocky Hoodie estuary
up to the Buddha Nui district boundary
when driving stay below the last high
tide mark and give way to people and
animals at all times you should be going
no faster than thirty K's an hour and
slowing right down to Tim Kaiser now
when within 50 metres of people so it's
not difficult keep to the designated
areas for approved purposes and drive
safely we've all got a part to play in
preserving our beaches and estuary find
out more at Waimea DG opt-ins ed board /
beaches
[Music]